nicolas le floch natif de guérande
démarre à paris en 1761 une carrière de
commissaire de police aux ordres du
ministre sartine ses compétences et la
confiance de ses pairs en font le héros
de six romans écrits par un diplomate
grand spécialiste du xviiie siècle mais
de la connaissance minutieuse de
l'histoire à la création d'un personnage
que l'on croirait réel quelle est la
démarche
j'ai pensé que d'une part beaucoup de
lecteurs avaient envie qu'on leur
raconte une histoire avait envie qu'on
leur raconte une histoire avait envie
qu'on crée des personnages qu'on crée un
personnage principal auquel ils
s'attachent puis il ya le problème des
dialogues au début quand j'ai commencé à
écrire je m'interrogeais sur ma capacité
à écrire des dialogues dans le ton du
xviiie siècle puis au fond d'une telle
telle appréciation de la littérature de
cette époque c'est venu assez facilement
alors on n'essaye pas de faire du
pastiche mais on essaye de faire quelque
chose qui soit vraisemblable c'est à
dire un dialogue qui s'ils étaient
écoutés par des gens dits xviiie siècle
leur paraître peut-être un peu étrange
mais pas trop
c'est au châtelet équivalent de la place
beauvau qu'officie le floch son rôle
entouré de fidèles collaborateurs
déjouer les complots mettant en péril la
royauté mettre de l'ordre dans les
bas-fonds d'une ville où les misère
engendre inévitablement les crimes mais
tout cela dès qu'on passion et rigueur
nous avons dans l'est
archives dans les éléments judiciaires
de l'époque des intrigues des histoires
qui sont similaires et avec des
personnages de la police peut être pas
aussi sympathique que nicolas le floch
mais c'est tout à fait un vrai flop le
flop né de l'imagination de son auteur
travers son époque mais ses romans
suivent une chronologie historique
imparable ils sont d'ailleurs conseillé
aux étudiants par leurs professeurs
d'université parce que derrière la
fiction se déroule l'histoire de france
au quotidien
[Musique]